hey guys it's a new podcast let's run
through some dates real quick before it
start go check out my youtube channel
you can find all my info at Bert Bert
Bert calm and that's where you can find
my YouTube page I post new vlogs
bi-weekly and the video to these
podcasts podcasts are posted on my
youtube channel so go check it out let's
run through some dates real quick as
always going to Bert cast get a shirt
get a machine shirt we got new machine
shirts coming out and coffee mug my book
life the party edmonton january
fourteenth through 16th Melrose improv
on the twenty-second liberty Ohio that's
right outside Cincinnati or inside
Cincinnati I think it's a new club I'm
going to be there the 28th through the
30th of January Richmond funny bone
februari 4 through 6 the ice house with
friends februari 12th Omaha 18 19 20 the
hard rock in sioux city is it sioux city
it's all of our city but Sue's one that
owns it I'm gonna be there on the
seventeenth of februari and Bellevue
Washington the 25th 26th 27th guys I
still have tons more dates oh my god how
do i forget i wanna fight call in sick
to work show in columbus ohio on the
seventeenth of march followed by the
long road distillery in Grand Rapids I
think it's Grand Rapids Michigan I don't
know virginia beach des moines calgary
brea DC helium schaumburg flappers
orlando columbus again albany funny
bones syracuse guys this is running up
until August I'm not going to tell you
more dates than that today's podcast
it's with a hilarious dude he's one of
my favorite comedians here's the guy
that taught me that if you were just
cool to someone then they'll be cool
back and he has been my friend since the
moment I met him and I've known him now
for probably 13 years put your hands
together stand-up comedian from the
nasty show from punch-drunk
from the comedy store and this is a bun
Nana's good podcast Sam Tripoli
perfect young creature that show was
[ __ ] fire ha it was pretty insane I
gotta be honest with you best set of the
night no questions asked Brody Stevens
oh you were yeah I was there during
Brody yeah I was uh I was I was actually
walking out but Joe uh torch the room I
mean there was no like one when Joe and
on I was it was when he said thank you
good night or whatever place went nuts I
don't think I've seen something like
that in a really long time just hardcore
[ __ ] do immediately everyone just
stood up said it like just oh you guys
standing oh yeah and he's got this bit I
won't tell you the bix I don't want to I
didn't burn his bit is it about what's
his face yeah oh it's phenomena
destructive I mean its destructive and
he's acting it out it's just like oh
yeah oh my god and I was oh [ __ ] off
side with the jessiemae peluso and we
were doubled after and we were doubled
over and we were critiquing the bit we
were like like figuring out what we
liked in it how everyone on next has
massive balls because it was tough
guessed it yeah right now right after
that was like it's my first time in the
main room and he I went on after him I
don't know I wish I knew because I
really [ __ ] respect that kid cuz he
met he did yell right no one Dean it was
a younger kid with a with a hoodie all
he had a orange get an orange a ski cap
on Adam was it Steve you know wealthy
holder who it was Adam I don't known
Adam I'm trying Josh I was a young kid
yeah young kid Josh Martin it might have
been laughs Todd like this I don't know
but he had a rough set but it was like
he's stuck it's like it's like they
shouldn't he's got stay in the plot yes
I can't a face tattoo you gotta calm
that's the comedy store dude the reason
if you're blessed to learn in the store
is that there's no hole stewed there's
really no host I guess last night they
did but you always have to go up after
like some dude just scorch
the earth and you gotta try to get
laughed like the two hardest people in
the world I've ever had the foul is
Leslie Jones Leslie Jones Leslie Jones
Sarah Night Live ghostbusters the big
black chick she's she's been doing
comedy since Christ was a kid I don't
know and she just got sent alive like
two years ago and go really and now
she's on like she's the black chicken
Ghostbusters and [ __ ] education have
to file that woman you got a folk at
that I have to script my first five
jokes yeah and just know nobody's gonna
be listening and the other person is
Joey Diaz at that room Joey Diaz I had
to oh I didn't press come on I didn't
have to follow Joey I I went up before
Joey twice last week we just Joey just
called was like let's go do sets so we
didn't win the set of flappers I love
flapper I love flappers to do love
flappers and I love you know what else I
love is the haha i love the new haha
it's like a new york city club in outer
space Judas looks like just a space jams
Chris come on leave us the [ __ ] alone
and so uh dog isn't like oh you don't
own a dog you have a roommate that's
because that's how big the stock g boy
doesn't realize like last night I came
out I wanted to talk to liane Lee and
give me a great [ __ ] pep talk Chris
come on are you [ __ ] serious Lee and
my wife oh go get that go get it we get
this dog thinks she's you like your
other dogs a little hot dog and so like
bill burr came over to a podcasting just
she sat on his lap and he was like I
love this but I like I can't breathe
yeah it's a hundred pounds of just all
love I came out to talk to liane last
night and Priscilla just came out and
just sat on her just lays across her
it's she gets in bed with us it's like
having a third human be it's like
running a train my I've been doing this
job rest no it's all common you like
coffee pris come on I've been doing
jokes I was telling the story about how
I always get hard to do where gigs and I
had to do a gig at a Las Vegas swingers
club and it was hilarious because it's
like you got to stand up why like black
guys run trains on fat white chicks and
it's just like he's got stay in the
[ __ ] groove and sweet do you think
you learned you
think you learned did you how much did
the comedy store inform how you do
stand-up you know it II completely one
hundred percent my whole Styles comedy
store it was detrimental at first
because I would go into like comedy
clubs in the Midwest and be like juice
flame throw the room and like there's a
there's an order in a business to a lot
of comedy clubs and on the road which I
totally understand that is not at the
comedy store yeah like The Comedy Store
thrives on chaos you know the weirder to
[ __ ] the crazy or the [ __ ] and just it's
outlaw stuff a lot not as much now as it
used to be but when I was coming up and
you know mitts he was barely there but
she's still running the place and it was
like the the the inmate ran the asylum
and it was just like it was just pure
chaos it's there is an energy I was
tired I'm not to like talk all about the
comedy store today but like they're like
I did two sets back to back at an irish
story telling Sean I did read man show
and I never work at The Comedy Store I
never work with the comedy store based
off of of fear that I'll bruise my
self-esteem you know I mean is that
sound fair yeah I get that like it's
like I'm not I never passed there so I'm
not in there so I can't just show up and
get on I have to be like put on a show
and a lot of times it's like you you
have to start from scratch at that place
but I feel like I don't think there's
anybody that would be upset if you just
if they you stuck in spots no no
everyone would love to have you there I
think I don't know maybe but I'd like
the thing is you know it's like this is
like super vulnerable for me to say
about be very honest it's the whole
showing up and having to explain to
someone you're a comedian when you been
doing at 16 years did I get all the ties
like I did already show and some door
guy very nice guy i'm sure was just like
hey man you can't go in this way i was
like i'm just going to belly room he
goes no you need to show your ID you
need to go into the front and I was like
Alma comedian because he's like he
didn't say it this way because like I
don't know you and I was like
unbelievable I was like god damn it and
then the guy next to him I was hoping
someone knew me and he was like he's
like a man you gotta go and you gotta
like I was at the door the belly room to
go out like at that back entrance and
then Harlan Williams just walked right
past me and
one said anything and I went he just
walked in this way and so I was like all
right now my ego is [ __ ] up so I go to
I tell re i'm like sorry I'm late I had
a hard time getting in it was like what
yeah you think I know you are listen I
go through that the improv in hollywood
improv yeah those door guys there's a
turnover there which I understand yeah
that's a bad play but everybody's a
comic the help they all want go everyone
says their comic and that's what I'm
saying what everyone says right like
listen officer I don't or i don't want
ever to anyone gets for a drinking
problem like i don't have a problem I
totally get it yeah like I go to calm me
I go to the improv and I go to walk into
like hold on do we need an idea I'm like
and then luckily there's art no he's
comic let him in but there's a ego thing
it [ __ ] with you listen man you know so
you night met a long time ago and we did
a DVD and everybody's kind of gone on
their own trajectory and that [ __ ] you
know and through a couple like weird
decisions in my life my trajectory has
been a different than a lot of people's
trajectories you know and it's just like
I feel like I get what you get the
economy store and a lot of place I get
it a lot of places stroy smile I might
type you know it's like I just like dude
you don't know me okay i guess i guess i
gotta go in here and just [ __ ] and then
you go up on stage and it just like
people I've done the hot I've done a
flappers yeah and they like I was doing
the you the you who room which I really
love that you room it's like a nice
place like i loved what i already did
like get a tiny room work your our out
jacket with your fans see if it works
pack it out I like doing that you know
give me a weekend I'll do half an hour
40 minutes onstage or just
flame-throwing people you know but it's
so funny one I got put I was due to you
who room they put me in flat in the main
room they're like you want to guest spot
cuz a couple of employees know who I am
like yeah so they put me up you know and
the kids are doing the best thing I'm
going up with like 23 year olds I've
been watching YouTube clips so they they
understand cadences and then they're
very polished unpolished [ __ ] you know
what I'm saying that it seems like it's
delivered by a [ __ ] Reno veteran
who's been doing like catcher rising
star green honest unpolished [ __ ] I've
seen so many guys I'm not
saying specifically at flappers or
anywhere but I have seen so many guys
doing exactly we're talking about very
polished unpolished [ __ ] yeah they've
seen enough to understand cadence they
just don't know why they're doing it
yeah yeah yeah they get the beats and
all that stuff you're like these kids
are way ahead of me when I was at that
age [ __ ] jaw oh god man I literally
was like watching this guy the other
night at some undisclosed location and I
was just like I was like I'm smiling and
I'm enjoying it but I'm not laughing
yeah like nothing he's saying is
original nor is it like interesting but
I get where I should laugh there's this
really funny on comic her name is taylor
Tomlinson and she is literally one of
the funniest young youngest funniest
people I've ever seen in my life yeah
she's I don't know if you know her story
she did last Comic Standing she got
pretty far but she started out in
churches cuz they wouldn't let her do
stand-up in comedy clubs you know they
wouldn't let her do stay up a comm club
so the only station she get was doing
these like church events so she worked
clean if these church events and then
she has this like old black man crowd
work that you walked like she's so would
have and you like watch her like holy
[ __ ] and she's like 22 and she'd like
kids at all this cop all this kind of
she gets it and like I was having her i
was doing a show with her somewhere and
I had you know Greg Wilson was watching
her and he's like yeah these young kids
they get it because they've been
watching YouTube forever and they
understand the cadence and all that
stuff but if you watch her her premises
are like from her age which is taco bell
and all that stuff but that's what she's
lived you know it's like the biggest
thing these kids have to do is like go
out live life before they could start
getting some real [ __ ] like it's the
same way everyone was copying Danes
cadence yes in like the late 90s because
we were like god I remember I distinctly
remember watching him the first time to
stand up and when he does he I can't
imagine him bombing like he just he's
got it hey uh give her get her noticed
that like it was just like so like
distinguishing like and I remember going
like I'm having jokes Rose like the joke
doesn't work but I bet if I repeat the
word four times I
that people will understand i'm walking
some warlock in one case waka too far I
want to gain hello I'm you know it's
yeah and it's a really smart way work
the thing that's up saying is like the
more you're around I'd like I feel like
it all the athlete like nobody knows
Shoeless Joe the chillest Joe's the
greatest ever you want shoes Joe you'd
laugh at cycle Jordan that yeah Shoeless
Joe yeah I needed everything Jordan did
but without shoes man and you're like
like that's kind of sometimes how I feel
about Dane Cook it's like you know with
all this crazy [ __ ] that went on with
him like nobody really appreciates like
there was a time about ten years ago
when he was the baddest man on the
planet like he was on I would watch him
at dublin's and just be like whoa this
guy is [ __ ] murdering people and it's
like he was the best what at that time
I've ever born up after one time in
thinking how do you now get them to
think about you cuz I'm still thinking
about him yeah I'm still thinking about
what he just said and I'm the one that
needs to talk he there was a time and I
remember it vividly where it was like I
remember saying to someone this must
have been what it's like to watch the
first caveman make fire like you've
heard stories about the fire but now
you're watching you like oh [ __ ] man he
does it every time 100 I mean he went
did you ever know Dublin's way back in
the day and you would just he would just
get up there and he'd get that he'd get
the prime spot and then it would just be
45 minutes of just this buh buh buh buh
buh buh buh buh buh sports chalet yeah
you just he would just take something
that was in the ethos that we'd heard
there was a sport chalet I take it to
the limit and he just sprinkled in
throughout his set and by the end
anytime you want sports chalet
everyone's on the [ __ ] floor I heard
a story one time he's like he was get
doing a college and he goes he's and by
the way I hate I had a I used to have a
friend who liked loved for you to talk
about him and then all of a sudden one
day was like [ __ ] keep my name out of
your mouth
get into it but yeah and so and so I
never speak for B&B from that I learned
a lesson never speak for people never
tell the folklore stories I heard that I
loved that I appreciate it because those
same people might find that as an insult
but I will tell you a story that I heard
from Dane that I'm not if it's not true
it's not true but I Dane was at a
college and he goes you want to see
something amazing there's before the
show started and they're like yeah what
he goes just watch like ladies and
gentlemen take cookie goes on a stage he
stands the applause stops and he just
goes pickles like [ __ ] three dozen
like pickles oh yeah it's I remember he
does he was like uh the whole thing I've
keep it simple stupid is just he was so
smart about how would he talk about it
was so relatable I remember him doing a
joke about a girlfriend had rape
fantasies cuz I've had girlfriends like
that my buddy in dish like you know I
just want you to come and take me and
it's just like he had a funny joke about
am I raping you good am I good raping
you good and I'm like [ __ ] why didn't I
think of that just gets so he was just
really good at just I don't want to call
pop comedy but it is kind of pop comedy
that's like very broad strokes
unrelatable [ __ ] that's just he was a
master oven yeah you know this is just
me talking it's like it is weird when
you see kids are like and you're like
you don't understand like how unfollow
ball he was at one point Oh unfollow
bowl is the is like that its your right
I'm but I but they're like there was I
think there's a I wouldn't say I think
there's a time but I think in that in
that time I think comedy was like I
never saw anyone bomb like no one was
bombing at the time everyone joining me
did it was such an injury what I do
right now is so much more open more in
than what I did back when I start when I
start doing comedy 20 years ago man
comedy was everything with Seinfeld it
was it was observational clean comedy
which I totally respect because I always
say you have to be you what
on stage you have to be you and I I
generally believe that seinfeld's act is
Seinfeld and you know I've seen
interviews with him how he talks how he
acts that's him he doesn't need my
validation but I'm just saying that's
why I really like Seinfeld because I
feel like he's a genuine dude on stage
but i was like i like i guess you can
call scumbag [ __ ] but i've always been
like really honest about my character
defects and my my vices and all that
stuff but back then nobody wanted to
hear it now it's like a totally
different thing like thanks The Comedy
Central and the internet and it's just
kind of changed where I think people
like I think everybody has a little
scumbag in them you know I'm saying the
internet what happened is so many people
started putting out it's like making
pizzas everyone stop was making cheese
pizzas for a while and then you were
like [ __ ] man I like anchovies yeah and
you just like and and at one point the
internet changed everything and
everyone's like well I actually like
anchovies too and I like the fact that
there aren't just cheese pizzas yeah I
think it should be a wide range of
everything and it should be an
experience of who you are and all the
weird me I i'm doing a joke right now
about smoking crack with this [ __ ]
silver robot guy in Hollywood how he
wanted to suck my dick and I had a fight
this cracked out robot stop him from
sucking my dick you know there's like
that's the stuff I want to talk about
Zoe when you got to the comedy how were
you when you got to the company store
about 26 ok this is in my 40s now
probably 98 99 I'd say it's about 2,000
ok and then so what was like who is the
big I literally have never hung out of
the store I mean it's it's a regret
because you were so store I mean if I
talk talk to me I talked Rogan about it
and I said one night I [ __ ] did a
show and we're at the store we're having
a drink i said you know i think if i had
been if I think if I'd hung out this
door I don't know if I'd be alive and he
was like yeah I don't think you would be
like he does I don't think I'd be
friends with you I've always said you
know you're great at something when you
change the rules right this is literally
I basically made it so they stopped
giving comics free drinks you know I was
such a
[ __ ] alcoholic drug addict no and
blow drinking and [ __ ] at that place
that they had to take away free drinks
there i joined i got in at the improv
randomly I don't know what was the
[ __ ] thing I don't know why i wasn't
i didn't have a connect there I just
reached out i said i'd like to work here
I don't know why the improv I don't know
why I picked the improv and I just said
I'll do anything it was it's the
beginning it's something I'm going back
to now I think in my life is this lose
piety play over piety and humility I
don't I do not I got to a place where I
[ __ ] started to lose my humility like
when that guy said to me I don't know
who you are my humility was know where
my humility was everywhere last night
when I walked up last night I was like
so I did a lot of soul-searching tried
to do a set again and I had a hard time
getting into the store and I was like
just don't go back Corey Bennett say
you're sick it doesn't matter it's just
a [ __ ] it's so interesting man I've
been trying to talk about that on stage
is like now that I'm in my 40s it's such
a blessing because like you are who you
are yeah like through your 20s you're
like I'm gonna change the world and then
like in your 30s like I'm gonna get paid
and your for you like this is who I am
this is who I am this is where I'm at I
don't give a [ __ ] I can't change it I
can't be better and and I'm and really
deep down inside I'm a very humble
person so I walked in last night and I
went up to the guy at the front and I
was like I was like this is what was
[ __ ] freak this is a part that
bothers me I go hi my name is / Chrysler
I've asset and whoever the guys were
gonna do it goes I know exactly the [ __ ]
you are and I was like listen I don't
work here a lot I don't know where I'm
going I don't I'd really honestly Sam I
don't know the difference between the
oor and the main room I didn't know
there was a difference I was like when
they said main room I went wait what
what's the other room I was like I
living at the belly room I know they got
the main room and then is the room with
the glass is that the o.r that's a hola
and so I didn't know where I was going
and I said to the guy I got don't know
I'm going he goes okay so he points me
back that way so he goes then I got to
go pass through the line of people and
people recognizing me and then I go into
the next bouncer I'm like [ __ ] here we
go again is where I get stopped and I go
hey my name's Bernie goes I know who you
are Bert you just head right back there
and I was like holy [ __ ] I walked back I
knew [ __ ] everyone Bobby Lee roles in
one of the [ __ ] greatest
dudes alive just such a monster he comes
in and he's like what's not Burt and I
barely know Bobby just through emails
and I'm like oh my god I felt so
comfortable and then I had a great set
and I'm [ __ ] left I was like do not
[ __ ] tempt your fake birth don't hang
out until to you know get the [ __ ] home
Ron White Rob White was like that he
didn't go around forever and then he
kind of showed up a little bit and now
any time he's in town he loves hang out
yeah I really I had a great time it was
fun watching it and the it's a private
club dude we're comedians can be
comedian it's a private club it's
different it's more relief in the Friars
Club yeah it's just an interesting thing
like here's a problem with the comedy
store it's like it's such an amazing
club it is literally the world's
greatest comedy club you can bang it's
like that in a cellar you know they're
the two best and yeah you know it's both
are just effing amazing [ __ ] amazing
you know my problems I was there for so
long it's like when you're getting so
many spots at the world's greatest
comedy club it can be like you can get
stuck there and I was there for so long
because I was just getting such good
spots i was working all the time i was
making [ __ ] a little bit of scratch
here i was doing a bunch of sponsorship
stuff so he's making money I wasn't on
the road so now that was the weird thing
is like all you guys were [ __ ]
destructive on stage but none of you
guys left like all you guys wanted to
stay at the store and like I feel like
the improv comics all of us they started
over there were like like I gotta get on
the [ __ ] road because we were tied
into the improv so we could get like hey
can I host in brea can i host in irvine
somebody's thinking of you erst up until
recently Sebastian never to the [ __ ]
Road Sebastian Caparulo I guess Caparulo
does road Cepero and Sebastian did the
road forever you know but uh a masz did
but a lot of people just stay there for
[ __ ] re are we there forever he would
only go out with ah you know what rogan
broke it was there forever rogue it was
there for a very long time was until he
had that fall out which I think I
thought it was like the greatest thing
to happen to him as much as it probably
hurt yeah if force them to go out you
know so now I'm like kind of just
catching up and going on the road and
I'm doing this big tour coming up called
the man he tore punchlines and slow
grinds and I'm doing like two weeks of
the Northeast and cola twice and slow
grind it's you making shirts yeah we're
gonna make it on it but it's been
nothing but chad sumac and we're doing
like which was sooo mocks [ __ ]
hilarious you know something he's gonna
love here now because he's like I was
telling I'm like he said you got into
podcast promote show i'm like i will
like i'm going to do crisis like oh man
you're nothing but great things about
Christ sure and you know him and I are
good we [ __ ] and I've been good friends
we both kind of at dance with our demons
for a while yeah both you know Donal
wreaked a lot of havoc party and Anna so
we're both sober and we're both kind of
going to go do this fun crazy weird show
we're going to like Buffalo we're doing
helium funny bones and Syracuse we're
doing Cincinnati Cleveland Rochester you
know just all these different things
it's all the tours are available on Sam
tripling calm you see where I'm come
through but it's the 19th through the
30th and I'm just doing like one nights
one night in different cities every
night that's the way to do it and just
drive and dude and just boom you really
have from city different city different
city all within that northeast to just
kind of just start kicking ass it's like
the comedy source of great places to its
my love that I want the connoisseur but
I got addicted to that nipple I didn't
want to get off it so now I'm trying to
get out there and just do some more
stuff and free up a couple spots for
some newcomers at the comedy store so
they can learn the kungfu man I've been
baptism by fire dude Rogan dice Eddie
Griffin for the first [ __ ] they said
surprise guest last night it was Martin
Lawrence really there was a surprise
guest Martin [ __ ] Lawrence I was
blown away I was like Martin [ __ ]
Lawrence is here I left Nate Diaz was at
the show Nate Diaz who dude how big is
that dude I'm six foot I didn't see him
I wish I had known he was arrow to
[ __ ] stayed he's about two inches
taller than me so that guy 62 man he
fights at 155 I would have to cut off
legs to fight at 155 I don't know how he
does it yeah he's huge I apparently like
he was at the show
I would have loved to i would have if I
had known he was I'd someone said he was
a show but i don't think i heard it i
think i was like oh yeah and I guess I
forgot I just was like I gotta get the
[ __ ] out of here you were here next week
I wanted you to do my naughty show it's
gonna be a good day it's Wednesday I
think I'd leave for Edmonton yeah we're
doing it next week in the main room not
it's during xmas weekends like you know
you have AV ends while their
competitions xbase and they have their
big convention in on days that's next
door to the comedy store so the whole
wheel it's just like a pornstar beehive
and every year I do like a naughty show
right knee in the main room so they all
come from there and they come into the
comedy store it was so funny and it's
another thing about like Joe Rogan and
and brian redban show it's like such fun
party people show up doo doo Roo uh I
saw on Kate q funny i say kk quigley ice
a cake you funny cuz that's what I
follower on yeah yeah yeah I saw her on
Kate's periscope there were two
pornstars their last yeah it's right
there with them do my friend kayla paige
and my friend and then this girl i met
akira blue I Sakura boat something like
that yeah I don't even know but I've
known Kate I've known kayla paige the
one porn star for years she hasn't she
doesn't do it anymore but like she had
the fight thing about her is she we do
all my naughty show videos and she has
like legit comedy timing in her delivery
like I could put her in any video and
she would deliver the punch line she got
she got like mainstream agent the signer
because of how she acted in my video she
was like little bit funny dude these
poor sighs and she's just so she remind
me so much of myself because I would
bring her on the road with me to do
naughty shows she would just murdered
really her pole dancing or barlaston her
comedy on C would murder and then nobody
would know who she was I'm like I can't
relate this is me as I feel but it man
was Fonda ditz like yeah we do not he
shows all over the place I'm trying to
do some new live streaming [ __ ] wait
what do you got like like because I feel
like I have too many uh I've too many
things going on I'm doing the vlog I'm
doing the podcast I'm doing TV I'm
trying to develop something for TV
doing stand-up like what are you like
we're because I look at re and I go or
he's got it dialed in it's stand up in
his podcast that's it yeah i was talking
to Rogan last night about it he goes
he's I'm not gonna speak for him he's
like I think you have too much [ __ ]
going on he's like you know when you got
and it's true like they called me with
this show idea and I'm working on this
story for ari's show and as soon as they
call me the show idea i start
daydreaming about that not my set that i
have to do that night right I was like I
gotta [ __ ] in call them back and go I
can't talk to you right now I gotta get
this set there's always a saying you
should when you're writing a project you
should finish writing that project then
move on to your next project but you
know I do to podcasts I've now starting
this video blog ranting show but you
know I see like more like I've always
wanted to do radio and I just see it as
like if I was a radio a big radio guy
let's say Colin coward I am going into
my radio show monday through friday
doing three hours each thing so i gotta
seize like each one of my podcast my
video say is just another day of me
going to work you know so it's not
really like i feel like i'm too busy
because i love creating I love writing I
love I'm like I'm clinically insane dude
I can't turn my brain [ __ ] off so the
best thing to do is just use it and keep
writing and writing and keep writing
weird [ __ ] and it's just like you know
I'm ready I want you know I'm really
like I've learned like I really like
writing for other people like I've I
didn't want to do that first cuz I don't
be a [ __ ] horrible ego but now i
really like writing for people man and
it's like i've been writing digital
series for people because that's kind of
how these kids haven't made like when we
were young dude it's like there's like
three channels there there was one
camera you could buy if you wanted to
make anything but still you had to shoot
on tape use the canon g too i think was
I have one I ended up buying one and and
you had to use that because it would
translate to television regular video
cameras didn't translate to television
nowadays I mean I went I mean talk of
you I and like just put in perspective I
drove this I saved up money it was
twelve hundred dollars I drove
Sammy's cameras I got the g thing and
still the audio suck because it was in
thing tried to buy like a row B or
whatever Mike attachment a boom mic and
so now I got everything dialed in and
even still editing it you had to plug it
into your computer and let you to let
all that play to upload yet to let it
all play and then [ __ ] it was so
painstaking to make a video the other
day I went on amazon prime i ordered a
camera that was like 400 500 bucks they
showed up the same [ __ ] day with a
memory card I drone I shot a [ __ ] I
shot a vlog and just posted it I was
like what the [ __ ] man so it's different
it's a different world it's a different
world and you know you know Kate
Quigley's one of my very good friends
like a long time she called me up she
was like oh should i do this bikini
thing where i show up everywhere i'm
like it's about to get wild west out
there if you whatever you can the whole
point of this now is how many people can
you bring to the big paid project your
other its television or movies so get
those fans however the [ __ ] you can it's
aggregating it's like if Hollywood new
to tube two chicks in the cup chicks
could bring 50 million people to a
[ __ ] ABC drama they would hire the
two chicks one cup girls yeah I was
going to do where are they now with the
two chicks one color where are they yeah
well it can't be good be good but you
gotta be good this number one video of
all time on the Internet you should have
been like that should been spun spun i
literally just today I was like I was
like I was like I'm gonna post this
video online I was like you know I'm
reading David Spade's book I should
place it right there and my if I'm gonna
do that I might as well put my book next
to it I was like god forbid this goes
viral maybe David Spade gets hit like in
a hit because of it but yeah why not
it's so funny the how different
everything's changed when did you start
doing the vlog and what's the vlog about
I just started it I like I couldn't get
my computer I had to set the cid youtube
account long time ago yeah when the
naughty show first started they had
millions of hits and then and this is
all like seven years ago that doesn't
sound like that long ago but in terms of
entertain
internet that is the dark ages of the
internet seven years ago so YouTube came
and just got rid of all my [ __ ] I would
you know I was on desk wad desk wats one
of the greatest things ever especially
from you know in terms of helping my
career yeah it's an amazing you know but
they were also player haters who hated
some of the stuff on so I just get
people flagging my [ __ ] constantly after
while YouTube's like you're done and
they swiped all like me like three
million views off this off you kind of
channel i had and i was just like so i
got really discouraged so I didn't do it
forever well I i love ranting like i
love to rant so I do a couple of RAM
podcast and everybody loved it but I was
like I don't want to do three podcasts
how can I do some different so I said
you know I'm gonna do a YouTube channel
where I rant once a week every thursday
at this time I'm gonna pick five
subjects and try to ran for an hour and
just go off and people seem to like it
so I just started last week I just put
up one like video about dog pants how
people are fighting about dog pants on
the internet like whether it should be
all four legs or just a hind legs it's
obviously it's all about your [ __ ] and
balls the whole point advances to cover
your [ __ ] and balls so and then it's
like how do you market this thing that's
the whole thing like what do you gotta
put in there that gets people to look at
it yeah and again it goes back to keep
it simple stupid dog pants people like
to talk dog pants you know I'm gonna go
off i'm making it a murderer probably
tomorrow you know have you seen it no
don't bring it up i'm a zinnia oh my god
yeah i'm in the two week where it start
p I started hearing about it to like a
week and a half ago and I'm in that
spectrum of like right now everyone's
and I got to watch it now or it's or the
statue of limitations is up you gotta
yeah yeah that's how I'm going to see
Star Wars tonight Oh statute of
limitations came up on that Sunday oh
really allowed to say whatever yeah Doug
Benson was like we I did the doug loves
movies' I oh no statute of limitations
up we're gonna talk about it and he just
they just end up by the way I their
parts I didn't know about the movie
because i was with patent and Doug yeah
and-and-and might be one of the top five
podcasts I've ever done is that episode
of doubles and Oswald patent on occasion
a mercenary like just a murderer
he's so fast he's so quick he I was
wearing I was wearing a sweatshirt like
a hooded sweatshirt a north face vest
and a ski cap and I guess I just looked
like a hundred different references that
he had in his pocket and he I mean was
so goddamn quick it was I it was and I
think that's what everyone loved about
is his patent making fun of me for 30
[ __ ] minutes so any time I'd say
something he would then drop a brand new
reference he's so smart I then I was
awed the best thing I've ever done is I
was like at the end of the thing I was
like and I appreciate patent wanting to
be on my podcast and so he came up to me
obviously I'd be on your podcast is that
that's great you got recognized as a gun
I love that saying he's gone recognizes
a gun a gun recognizes a gun you know
you just know when you watch somebody
like that's one of the best and there
was one thing when I used to be in vain
when I first moved to Vegas within like
the first three four years every week
there was a new gun in duh I'm like [ __ ]
another guy who just go up there and
just [ __ ] fourth were people showing
up to Vegas like with chops no Vegas is
a totally different thing when I was in
LA I would say Vegas is like Vegas now
has a really nice scene I just think
some of the comics don't hustle enough
they just you gotta grind hard but
there's so many stage time they just
opened another comedy club so there's
like five or six comedy clubs there's so
many places of work and I think vagus is
going to eventually become an artist
community work because he's caught these
casinos they have like three or four
stages in each casino and now instead of
having one show / stage they now have a
different show every two hours so
there's so many there's so much
opportunity to get up there I'm trying
to get back to Vegas really I wanna be I
want to do the road and duvet look at my
dream is a late night like Don Rickles
show where I could just claim be great
would that be I just want to do a man
charged go doing it it's like Vegas Lee
I do comedy come like how much it takes
is like 40 bucks I'm like you're
charging 40 bucks people wanna pay if
you go to vegas and like hey this shows
20 dogs like something's wrong with that
show yeah that is the crazy part is that
if they don't
ask a price a premium for the ticket
people think they're not getting their
money's worth yeah so they like oh hey
$45 see a twenty dollar shell I'd love
to get a room in vegas and like i used
to love I see love did you ever do
Joaquin and uh yeah did their show this
week oh really they got a new room it's
in the it's in the LA it's in the
stratosphere it's called the LA comedy
club and I just did it to the
stratosphere yeah it's great dude really
like almost like they took the o.r to
connoisseur and did a mini version of it
did you smell your feet did you see I
respect that they're smelling nuts all
the time like okay we're not something
came out from the moment I was like I
gotta find out what that is wait I love
those guys that we did I got we they I
didn't they didn't they never [ __ ] me
over but there was one time were where I
get you know they were it was when they
were trying to move things around and
they were short on money one we can and
the reason they're good now is because
they get the bar comedy club owner
doesn't get the bar it's always gonna be
weird on checks yeah and and I never had
any ill feelings towards them and they
were never they were never dicks to me
and they were very upfront like listen
we do not have it right now when we get
it will pay you and they're good and
they were good but my wife's one of
those people that was like one selfish
never forget once someone didn't a check
dingo through this is more like back
home like not saying we don't need money
now but we really like if I went on the
road we were out of pocket well I've
always said that about you know it's
like there's some comics and that it's
like give me that check dog I'm yeah
check his bills are gonna need to get
paid man no they got this little room
it's called the le conical I just did it
and like on a Monday night it was packed
it's like it's packed all the time and
it's like it's dark comic clubs need to
be like strip bars man pitch black
nobody sees what's really going on and
you could go [ __ ] off on people and
they like the when the rooms really
bright like The Laugh Factory it's so
bright if you're doing a really dark
dirty joke which makes people laugh but
they don't want anyone to know they're
laughing at that joke it ruins of I a
dark room people like hahahaha and
nobody sees who's laughing it's the
reason office parties at comedy clubs
suck it's
cuz when you're like yeah buried an ass
and everyone's like whoa it's my boss
right there I I got one of the first
gigs ever did jason clare do you know
Jason glue yeah Oh one of the greatest
human beings on the planet did one the
great he heals hey man I got this gig
for you I I was supposed to I can't do
it it's five hundred dollars and I was
so young five bucks I'm there [ __ ] it
mm-hmm you gotta go to Arizona okay you
got it you're doing stand-up for
accountants on a moving bus that's going
from Phoenix to laughlin nevada and you
got to entertain them and I'm like 500
bucks I don't give the ball to Nevada
yeah I'm going I'm interstate on a gang
okay I get up there they're like it's
listen man this is a corporation as
their corporate gig you gotta work clean
I'm like what why am I here [ __ ] why am
I here so they're like we're clean so I
started just doing Stan and then I ran
out all my cleans I start doing and I'm
bombing dude I am bombing but I'm trying
to think of friends jokes like what's a
clean free I'm doing I knew Nick
swardson's joke I'm bombing I am bombing
dude I eat to like just sit down okay
anybody wanted to stand up so they all
took turns une stand up there like and
it was all like you ever been to Bob's
cubicle what's up with all those
pictures my kids do you have Bob how
many do you have oh he's talking to Bob
when woman goes he's funnier than in the
comic I'm in the room cuz I Bob before
you can get my car go home lick my
wounds I'm going cross state lines with
people who hate me there's no getting
out of it it was awful dude it was awful
Jerry here bill burr story of he won't I
don't know if it's by almost certain
it's bill he they had stand up and they
accompanied it and they give him tickets
to a [ __ ] playoff game for the
Yankees but he had to do comedy on the
bus and yeah I've heard about those
things and it's just [ __ ] just I've
just [ __ ] sucks dick I corporate
every corporates always pay well but
like I never it's not my sweet spot and
it's not the thing I like doing it's
almost like if they hired I'm not saying
I'm Picasso
they hired Picasso to paint a house yeah
like I'm not a house painter yeah I
understand that i paid someone to paint
my house I understand the pain in the
ass yeah I but I'm not a house different
kind of pain and difficulty painting I
can I i can [ __ ] in paint my pictures
and that's all I really like doing have
you ever met a comic named Jason rouse
yes rouse is a great example this guy
got he got hired to a vegas gigging if
you know rouse you know his comedy no
but it describes Jason roust everyone he
is like he's shaved head gold teeth
shaved head gold grill yeah wife is like
where my canadian death metal comic
death metal just leathers [ __ ] hood
ring last though like when you talk to
him he's on fire yeah but he's 14 true
last Mohicans yeah really what are u %
murder murder murder he is hired to a
gig at the like em hotel in Vegas for
elderly people and he bobs the guy who
books him at bay loses the gig are you
serious that Jason hey you cost my
family money so two weeks later I'm
going to Vegas and I'm trying to do find
a place to a naughty show in Vegas I
mean what this guy goes yeah I booked a
lot of shows I book you know the mo
toggle hola are you the guy that book
Jason rouse he's like yeah did you book
Jason rouse for clean shell he's like
yeah I'm like what the [ __ ] is wrong
with you if you just googled his face
you'd be like this probably is the wrong
guy yeah he goes he signed a contract
weekly I go that's not him man there are
clean comics out there you hired and it
doesn't work that way it never works
that way where they go you get a phone
call listen can you work clean for one
hour yeah no comic that does like I'd be
like know what happens is they go we got
you a gig it's in dot dot dot the it's
some price point that you've net you're
getting 20 grand you're like whoa what
the [ __ ] yeah really and they're like
yeah are you in you're like [ __ ] yeah
man all right great all you got to do is
like 45 minutes you're like great then
you get there and they give you a beat
sheet of what you're not allowed to talk
about you're like [ __ ] and it makes
sense for 20 grand or whatever the
[ __ ] high prices yeah i understand i
probably can't talk about [ __ ] [ __ ]
farts
I you didn't need to put that on a
bullet point I said I had a gig one time
I didn't get one time they said don't
and I'm never gonna say the name of this
company they go don't talk about the
fact that it's all men here don't talk
about the fact that they're all
millionaires don't talk about the fact
thrall white don't point out that
someone isn't white don't point out that
and they're like what we want you to do
is celebrate being rich I'm like I'm not
[ __ ] rich and they're like no like
talking right talk about doing rich
people things I'm like I don't know what
the [ __ ] that is and it was more money
than I had ever been offered and I just
went up and ate a dick for an hour did
check cash check cash oh man we got done
the guy bunch of the guys that worked
there they were like you said it was
okay we just want to party with you I
was like what like we just want to party
with the machine yes I got that I got up
in the first thing out of their mouth
television story like by the way there's
a company they're like tell the Machine
story and i go i'll get to it knocked
out now these are [ __ ] millionaires
they do not want to be told what to do
tell now I tell the Machine story ok all
right he's done like that's 10 minutes
of a [ __ ] hour set and then I went
and party with him all night long and
that's all they really wanted is to [ __ ]
a party of course I broke all the rules
I [ __ ] pointed out the one Indian guy
[ __ ] talked about the one black guy
long as it goes well they don't care but
these long sleeve down case does go Bell
does go well they could be like we
[ __ ] told you yeah and and they were
really cool they were they were really
cool but i can tell you hun with the
uncertainty I did not I did not have my
best our on stage it was I was tough I
still have the not only comparing
against you what you normally did he
I've seen a lot of stand up to uh yeah
I've it was mediocre it was we used to
genuinely mediocre at best baskets and
air like he was okay but yeah it was uh
it was fun though I mean it's an
interesting story I don't give a [ __ ] I
break everything down to uh sex worker
brackets like am I making crackhead
[ __ ] money am I making stripper money
am I making escort money for making
escort money for making money
that rich men pay hot chicks to [ __ ]
them for I'm doing pretty good man you
know and if you just go up and you're
doing a clean you gotta do a clean show
I could do a clean show I can just crowd
work to the end of days yeah what always
happens is the crowd wants me to go
filthy yeah cuz it's real and it's no I
did I the venture a harbor comedy club
and like that like don't talk dirty I'm
like why am I here yeah and I just
started interviewing this couple this
elderly coupled about 75 each all they
wanted to talk about is how much [ __ ]
they're doing they just see well that's
a it's like yeah there's someone's
putting parameters on a group of people
that haven't asked for the parameters I
mean sometimes they do ask for the
parameter sometimes you're like I went
and did I'm doing it again I once again
I won't say the name of the company but
I'm doing it again I went in and I was
like and they're like you know you got
to be clean you doing like 10 minutes I
was like I can do 10 minutes clean and
they're like and you know they give you
some guidelines and then I get there and
I meet the president of the company goes
it's my [ __ ] company if I don't laugh
then you're not coming back and he goes
uncle [ __ ] what you talk about talk
about anything just make me laugh and I
was like done I went up first [ __ ]
joke I tell us his joke about eyelet
putting her finger in her ass place goes
[ __ ] nuts and he's just sitting there
man you gotta give it to this guy
hopefully this never gets back to him
notnot I'm saying anything bad but like
I don't know if he was doing this on
purpose that's why but meant you know
what he did the president of the [ __ ]
company he stood up out of his seat like
Robert De Niro and [ __ ] cape fear and
started laughing hard as [ __ ] and the
second he laughed everyone was like it
doesn't matter no rules our presidents
laughing were all having a good that's
all good was like he was a [ __ ] I
looked at him do that I went this is a
really great guy he just made my [ __ ]
week my day [ __ ] brilliant and I
gangsta route I [ __ ] I said I said he
came up to me the next day and he was
like you [ __ ] killed you made me
laugh and he was like every [ __ ] year
for the rest your life in one year and I
was like it's just I was a great gag
walk and it was like men that guy I
remember thinking I learned a lot from
that guy cute he knew everyone's names
that were he worked with he knew
everyone's names he took the time to
[ __ ] take moments to share with them
it's like
rogan does it with like with fans Rogan
literally goes I'm gonna [ __ ] take a
picture with every single person who
wants take a picture never seen it and
like that before like when I used to gig
with him dude one step through an
airport picture another step picture
another that picture yeah and he always
was really nice man I couldn't do you
know man I love Joe Rogan man he's done
more for comedy than anybody know I
could not do his job I could not do
where every word that comes out of my
mouth is over analysed to the end of
days yeah I could do it I like being
under the radar I like being under the
radar like like the fact that I know
that even the stuff we're saying right
now like a lot of people here but we're
never gonna get held to the fire for it
yeah we could say whatever the [ __ ] we
want no one's gonna we're not getting
fired for anything we're saying but man
I list I said that about Jesse man i was
sitting there last night he said
something like he's we were like it's i
love that he's unapologetic for who he
is and he says things that that in a out
of a different mouth might be like I
would be like I would be like I don't
know man like it's it's it's palsy it's
like palsy the key to this saying he
goes he's like I'm talking about his
daughters like I'm turning into a [ __ ]
and it just is like I don't give a [ __ ]
that you could analyze that nine ways
from Sunday on [ __ ] some alternative
talk show of what I just said this is
what I'm [ __ ] feeling yeah it was
like put Jesse and I were like both
sitting there going like I [ __ ] that's
what I love about a stand-up he says
it's [ __ ] him it's real and he's just
one of those guys that like the
punchline is the exact perfect punch
line for what he's coming up with when
you hear great dog that's great pride it
could be a better plan now we're rogan
everything is completely and utterly the
best punch line you could have at that
moment yeah he's uh he's and he was
total stream of conscious last night
like you you have a fedora honor you are
a man of many hats right that's what
that's what Rogan is yes he has to
remember whatever he's saying is
determined by what hat he's wearing at
that time as to stand up he can say
crazier [ __ ] but as a UFC commentator he
has to watch what he said like that
thing is like another like hats like the
stuff they got in trouble with for sings
about cyborgs you know it's like
Christine sideboard when Tony
Hinchcliffe's like yeah she's the only
cut way by cutting off her dick I
understood why she got upset because Joe
Rogan is the John Madden of that sport
like please what a Tony it slips away by
coming over yeah this this Christina
cyborg is this amazing fighter she's a
chick but she has like man skills you
know like it i've seen different ways
and I like where fights and I can
understand why your feelings were hurt I
mean I understand why we forget she's a
person also yeah and it's like I don't
know how to explain it it's like if
you're doing stand-up and the head of
comedy central goes on a podcast and
racks you a little bit they're like oh
man's a guy who decides everything it's
like you know I know Mike you mean I'm
dead on the inside but that that hit the
last nerve laughs I know funny yeah but
Rogan smart enough to go out making a
pot like he's so self-aware that it's
really amazing and it's like I was kind
of hoping cyborg and Ronda Rousey would
end up fighting they still made but you
know it's like I think right sigh i
think the UFC as you know dan white such
an interesting person because you know
really [ __ ] it is he's so it cuz he
literally created a billion dollar
industry i remember i remember in
college getting high as [ __ ] going i
want to create a sport me and my buddy
Eddie were like let's create a sport and
so we literally freeform just try to
think of how we could create a sport yes
Dana White created a sport out of
nowhere dude another American made spoil
its Gracie's but they made it the
Gracie's in the Gracie's baby where I
guess in that time but Dana White it's
like look you can say mate Howard
Naismith or whatever created basketball
but yeah and I'm not by the way I'm not
take away from the Gracie's whatsoever
but it's it's Dana took it to next Lena
took it to the next level and said no I
believe in this [ __ ] I love this [ __ ]
this is my this is what I will dedicate
my life to I don't know Dana story but I
do know the one I have in my head like
I'm a [ __ ] Boston bouncer yeah who
[ __ ] got punched in the head a bunch
and [ __ ] it this is my ticket yeah I'm
gonna [ __ ] do this and he still has
that
I sub mentality of white people love him
it's like it's why do people like Trump
regardless if I'm not making any come
yeah not making anything right now I
don't I don't vote for either the
parties and I know anyways but the point
is like why they like Dane white because
he's just so [ __ ] honest he's real
which is why people like Donald Trump as
much they might hate his politics a
we're just so used to getting lied to by
our pilot that sound just like not I
don't like that i'ma [ __ ] them over imma
bet you're like well at least we will we
got somebody shoot from the hip that's
Dana White now I so I only say that
because like Who am I to critique Dana
why I've never create a multi-billion
dollar industry yeah but what I will say
is like I feel like they missed the ball
sometimes and they should have they
should have promoted Christina cyborg
that's another female that is a murderer
yeah they could have made a brand out it
but they were so protective of Ronda
Rousey and I get it it's like when Ronda
Rousey's like I'm hosting sat night life
thats everywhere she gets into places
that Jon Jones they wouldn't Ellen
they've never had zhangzhou you do you
think they do you think that do you
think that they looked at it and they
were like we need to create one star and
we need to protect that star as opposed
to create like it's better to have the
Celtics for them as opposed to the
Celtics and the Pacers which are playing
really well as well but everyone wants
the Celtics to win anyway yeah yeah well
I think they didn't know what they had
and that female MMA is the most unique
thing in that it's the first time you
could have women competing against women
but I'm in an event dominated by men you
know it's like the closer you had Danica
Patrick but she never won anything yeah
but here you can put cuz she's going up
against guys whether a woman can
wouldn't ask are not that's not why I'm
discuss I'm talking about you were able
to put a woman in a vent they had all
men where she dominated people in
spectacular form that people like whoa
what's this unicorn and then because
women you know the most amazing study
every month at just changed
entertainment was when they discovered
that women are seventy percent of the
buying power so they know that at home
the people they really give a [ __ ] about
are the women they're gonna go to the
store and buy everything it's so
interesting you're saying this you know
only fight my wife has ever wanted to
buy was the Ronda Rousey fight and my
wife does not like UFC like she will she
has no interest in conor mcgregor
although we ended up buying that fight
she didn't watch the fight she was
pretty quick but you didn't watch the
fight but when we were over at our
friends house to cruise and she was like
she was like are we gonna get the Ronda
Rousey fight and I was like I was like
right someone else's house I mean I told
him I said hey if you buy it I'll pay
I'll pay for it and my buddy arcs like
seriously you know what else that fight
did is when she got beat it put there's
an there's like an empathy that
sometimes is numb to me when you watch
like when i watch hose out I don't get
jose aldo get [ __ ] knocked out i
wasn't like oh my god like I was like
yeah but when Rhonda got knocked out
everyone's like [ __ ] man i just watched
someone get i like it's almost like it
you could taste it again well it's also
like at the end of the day it's like we
don't like seeing women get beat up I
mean it's just the truth and we could be
like better equal women are you but at
the other day nobody likes there was
nobody likes to see a woman get beat up
and there was another fight this joanna
champion jezus Jack whatever name is
she's the one 15g i call him the violent
stick figures she's the 115 champion
she's taking on this girl Carla I don't
know her last name but Joanna champion
Joanna violence destroyed this chick and
it was hard to watch this flop the
raptor beat the [ __ ] out of this would
change it I mean dude you go back you're
like oh oh I never you could hear the
whole the whole place got quiet and
everyone's like oh my Oh did not the
fight because at the end a nobody wants
see girls keep I mean like and we listen
people sign up for this [ __ ] you know
but still hard to watch so when Rhonda
gets knocked out and just I and I was at
sales comedy whole listening watching it
and I was like I just yelled watch for
the head kick and just within two
seconds because that's what Holly Holm
does yes
a vicious she's a Dominator of
everything she's been a champion in box
was she gonna fight again what when she
fight next she's gonna proud they they
were trying to make her hold off till to
fight Rhonda but now they're gonna have
a probably fight cupcake I forget what
the chicks name is but she's they're
probably gonna have a fight cupcake
Miesha Tate mishit a and that should be
good I mean I would like to see I'd
rather see holly holm vs cyborg I think
that's a [ __ ] insane fight bones is a
real deal man real deal man she's been
fighting championships stuff for a while
when they when Dana White's like no
they're gonna have a rematch I'm like
Dana you're killing a cash cow yeah
you're killing this cash cow you gotta
give her time to practice now here's the
thing re and i have a bag of bats from
our punch drunk yeah and it's basically
like I believe Hawley homes will win the
rematch he's taken he's taken out Ronda
Rousey loser has to reenact gay porn
like we are we're gonna write out a cape
horn see that we have to reenact and
they could get as crazy as possible I'm
a pocket or you do all stuff I lost a
bet to re had to take boner pills and
ecstasy and watch two hours of gay
pornography like ah nexium Boehner bill
and we didn't live streamed it so people
could call in and tell me what porn the
watch and it was all like compilation
porn so I was just just [ __ ] pounds
of man juice just shooting on everybody
I had to do two hours of that man it was
robbed dude how long have you guys been
doing punch drunk for years well it's UT
Benari yeah how steep doing keeps doing
great man he's there ran into him
recently he was at the store last night
I was busy great man he's doing great
you know everybody's got their own
journey and he's doing great he's
literally one of the fastest dude you'll
ever meet in your life there's a logo
he's just the sweetest guy and he's so
honest and so vulnerable that podcast he
did with Ari about his drinking was one
of the [ __ ] best podcast I've ever
trauma you know there's some people like
that like Bret Ernst I always said is a
good-looking guy ugly people problems I
was said that like he's been through
some trouble that's why they're funny
yeah you know I'm saying like
you'll be amazed at how similar comics
and porn stars are dude i know we have
no bread on the podcasting I've never
had brown the pocket I gotta have a
little podcast fairies yeah he is he is
he's one of the sweetest guys alive who
genuinely but man we did a show together
that it was the funniest [ __ ] thing
I've ever done and I spent like a
weekend partying with them and doing
this show and I don't think I've ever
laughed more to person that wasn't
trying to make me laugh just literally
just naturally funny funny and when he
wasn't trying to be funny and funny when
he was trying he is a hilariously dark
human being like yeah like the [ __ ] that
goes through his life like he's so [ __ ]
he's got stories for days he really does
days do like crazy [ __ ] you're like how
are you still alive [ __ ] you know yeah
and have you seen his wife no oh my god
the guy knocked it out of the park do
really like Jesus Christ I couldn't date
that I couldn't marry that hot I would I
would be like where you going where you
going cuz you just know she's [ __ ]
kicking dicks away all day everywhere
she goes Dick's throne and dig dig dig
and you just got hope she's a goalie
good enough goalie stopped from anybody
scoring dude what's he doing see on the
road these days he rode dogs in a lot
really yeah he's road dogging and he's
like pitching he's just like us to
pitching trying to sell some stuff I
just feel like this is a great time to
be a comedian in LA a great time to make
[ __ ] yeah I'm gonna piss real quick all
right tell everyone about your tour tell
them where they know I'm just gonna piss
outside okay if inform everybody okay I
love that you're pissing outdoors I feel
like nobody does that enough I feel like
people dude I like to find weird places
the piss too that's my big thing I can I
get away would I just feel like you know
if you get caught pissing outdoors you
can get you might have to register as a
sex offender like how ridiculous is that
all right the man he tour with mean Chad
sumac January nineteenth were Buffalo
helium's january twentieth set Syracuse
funny bone we just added January 21st in
Cleveland the manhole hall room ah we're
at the youngstown comedy cellar
Friday and Saturday January 22nd 23rd
the Cincinnati funny bone the 24th
Columbus showbox the 20 januari 25th
Wednesday's I'm in cortland back in the
607 my buddies bricks his club his
nightclub I'm playing there then we're
finishing out thursday through saturday
at the rochester comedy club so come out
rock out in the next week is the naughty
show with fleshlight it's gonna be nuts
we got Bobby Lee Ari Shaffir Tiffany
Haddish Jason Ryles Eleanor Kerrigan and
jason t boat have you ever worked you
know you scale your podcast Eleanor
Kerrigan that woman is a monster she is
she the she's to work at the store ask
you something real sure of course you
ever have bad sets yeah of course really
yeah like what's a bad set to be honest
uh the other night uh at flappers I had
a bad set like like what is not have a
bad like my back my version of my bad
set is what I guess probably i'm trying
to think of like at the right analogy of
like i don't think people realize it's a
bad set because then i just what I do is
I go to a bunch of bad habits so like I
try something genuine and Trump try
something real and then uh like I went
into the you who room and I told the
story that I've been wanting to tell I
told one time on Elliott in the morning
and it really killed on radio and
everyone wanted here and I was like all
right that's the that is yeah go play
outside yeah I'll tell you you can hear
me and so I told her on Elliott the
morning and it was this great story and
then and then I was I tried on stage
couple times they just [ __ ] bombed
and I was like all right I'm gonna go do
the you who room and I'm gonna tell this
story and I'm gonna make it work and I
told him the you who room and it
completely [ __ ] worked and I was like
[ __ ] great oh it worked perfectly and
I was like that's it I got it nailed it
um I think it was I think it was because
it was so intimate I think it was so it
was so intimate and I was so confident
on stage that I think everyone liked it
and so then I go into
I go into the main room and I tell this
item and I got the [ __ ] thing behind
me and I do like a little bit of [ __ ]
around up front then I go to tell the
story in this story just [ __ ] falls
flat and I was like [ __ ] so then and I'm
doing ok I think I mean I think I'm
doing fine but what happens then as I
get I it's a instead of saying I'm gonna
stick with and I told the whole story
but as opposed to saying I'm going to
stick with working on this new [ __ ] and
trying to be good I just do a bunch of
easier [ __ ] like Bam Bam Bam Bam Bam
that's so injured so psychological isn't
it and it so into like I I think people
like adam hunter was like great set but
I think he hadn't seen me in a very long
time so a lot of stuff that I said I was
I wasn't proud of like even last night I
had a really good set and I was like but
I was like I was like I don't know The
Comedy Store is weird for me because I
feel like I gotta do well because if I
don't do well then anyone that Sarah's
like why would we let be on our stage
you know like so I feel that every time
I hit the stage yeah I think I feel the
pressure to just I did hooters has a
comedy club out here upstairs word I did
there's this sound Hollywood Boulevard
it's they've taken the top area and
turned to a little comedy glove hooters
yeah I could [ __ ] the Hooters on
Hollywood over by island I love that
place thank you i'll send you the guys
info did he pray allah i love it i mean
like dude I'd such a good time it's like
you gotta find a room to work on new
[ __ ] and that's the I know where I do
and that metabolic were used to do red
rocks oh yeah I love man ball game yeah
Matty ball game I used to love doing
that room because you could really do
new [ __ ] and you could really take a
chance and there was no one from the
industry there and like that's the other
thing is like I go up last night and
it's [ __ ] sold out I mean it's packed
and and I'm like and it's funny because
we're in the back and they're like
daliyah's going up and so Rogan and I
are talking and then Brian comes off
from he's like where's Leah and I was
like and he's like when he's like he
said he wanted to go up now he had
another thing to do and then they're
like I'm just listening going with my
set
and and all the sudden I hear them
applauding and Brian of red banners
attorneys like oh you're up Bert and so
like [ __ ] did he not go up no went up
after me but he was he he was I guess he
I guess he was just [ __ ] walking
around he wasn't right there and they
had said Bert's going up next to the
host David I think his name and so here
David eerie and so so yes I but I don't
know man I I don't think I think I'm
past this one when I bomb I it is a
somewhat of a conscious decision to do
poorly oh I'm so understand that but
yeah it's not like I'm and then this
isn't a sound like two people listening
I could say to you and you know what I'm
saying but people listening I don't want
you to think that like I decided to take
it into the [ __ ] what is what is
happening when I'm bombing playing into
the building yeah like I decide that I
am NOT going to fallen into my bad
habits and do stuff that I know works
and just get out of it because that's
not why I'm here I took I said this is
already the night too i said i was
talking about the flappers set i was
like i am there because Richie trusts me
and he knows that I can do well but more
importantly he likes me as a comic he
wants to see me create so that's what I
want to do is I want to create I want to
make new [ __ ] so like like I if I'm
gonna do poorly it's because I'm trying
to do something new he got to you got it
you got to fail man the biggest [ __ ]
the biggest flaw with so many comics is
they were terrified to fail that's
that's my biggest problem with LA right
now is everybody's doing power sets all
the time yeah there's Joey Diaz and I
Joey's I think Joey might be coming over
in like 30 minutes but Joey Joey Diaz
said to me we were like you know I love
Joey because no one knows certain sides
Joey that we all know like everyone just
sees him on his morning joint or hears
him on the podcast podcast I don't he's
like I Joey's a little hard to put your
finger on I told him you were coming
over he goes i'll be there at noon so i
should you should ask him about the
Twitter war ii just got in with John
Caparulo what happened they just went at
each other are you [ __ ] serious no
dude I'm not kidding
they just [ __ ] one at each other I
don't know what it's about I think it
has to do with I don't want to put work
him about it yeah but chose one of those
weird guys he may not talk about it no
dude he was going off on Caparulo so he
may want maybe he's I want to talk about
that but there could be a good chance he
does so funny I've never met Caparulo
kevro's a good guy you know he's a good
guy he's just like he's a he does his
own thing dude and you know what do you
mean doesn't thing like just he was part
of the comedy store for a very long time
and then like you just stopped being
part of the whole thing he said
comm.restore born and bred and they just
stopped coming around he stopped
interacting with a lot of people i don't
know why but stopped in like coming
around like stopped interacting meeting
like cognizant lee or did he just have a
family and i mean that that is what he's
saying I have a wife I just had a kid I
can't come around anymore I mean I hate
not to I don't know him and I'm not
gonna take it side on anything but I
have to say like one of the biggest
hindrances I have to go into the stories
like last night last night I would I
[ __ ] I and this is I think this is the
beauty and the evil of the store is like
I take my family out bowling with our
friends and I'm like I'm not gonna party
come loose at tonight but I'm in my head
I'm like I gotta set at the store I want
to make sure I do well in my head about
and I know that I'm gonna run today
you're being so honest with that I am
suck dude I have to jog and meditate
sometimes before I go onstage because my
head gets so [ __ ] nuts oh I was I was
there and I [ __ ] and then I'm like
all right I bowled a whole game with the
girls it's 830 I go I can get to the
store in 12 minutes from I'm gonna take
an uber over so I can drinks I know I'm
gonna see everyone and and and I was
like I want to have a few cocktails and
maybe I'll maybe I'll hang out but I go
I shouldn't hang out I got a podcast for
Sam in the morning so I got this all I
get in the car I drivers I get taken
over the store I get the store i'm
getting ready go on stage I'm sitting
with Rogen and my wife text me she's
like hey do you have the keys to the car
I was so in my head about my set that I
had [ __ ] taking an uber over in a
head and then I go yeah I go sorry just
take an uber home and then I and then
she texts me again [ __ ] our house key
are on there like oh [ __ ] and so but and
then I'm like and then I start partying
I have a good time in it but part of me
is like I get home I'm like I gotta be
dad the morning I gotta make breakfast
burritos I got it thank God I'll is like
a STONER I love [ __ ] woke I was still
in bed probably but but like but like I
can understand where capital would be
like would be like you know hey I'm I
have a family things obtained I totally
get it so hard man so are the arguments
about you'd have to ask them their to
the two killer comics I don't know I
never met John Caparulo I've Bret Ernst
loves him and then I've his friends with
Brett so that's the only way I know of
him is through that he was like he's the
last guy to ever really get a deal on in
Montreal he was the last guy about 10
years ago yeah I don't know if they've
done they still do deals but he was the
last time to get a big deal out of
Montreal but chicken was the last one
chicken up or chicken man crazy times do
I wish that I had been I wished it and
I've told you this million times but
I'll say it one more time because it's
the [ __ ] greatest thing ever Ewan
already taught me so much about about
being a good person in this business
because the first time I met you you
walked right up to me you're like hey
man I'm Sam I [ __ ] think you're funny
as [ __ ] we're about to do that show and
I was like and I was so intimidated by
you and I was like he didn't have to be
nice he could have just not spoken to me
which is what every [ __ ] comic does
and then he would've gotten in my head
and then I would have had a shitty set
and then he might have had a better sex
I'd of [ __ ] he said instead you got you
were positive to me and I felt
comfortable and then I had a good set
and you also had a [ __ ] good set and
ari was the same way i went up to all
and because i want I walked up to her I
go hey man my name is burnt I think
you're really funny and art was like I
think you're really funny and then we
became friends oh that's great but I
don't know why we were so chickens one
of those guys that I'm met before that
and he was just stand offish and so I
was ten times more standoffish and Reno
Collier wasn't was in between us and he
was really nice but you reno didn't want
to have to broker a friendship so he
just [ __ ] was like I'm gonna go drink
yeah yeah then I never spoke to chicken
once if people scare me i want to be
friends with them like a gun recognizes
a gun and when I realized there's a
quick gun here I want to be friends down
I'll go up and introduce my I introduced
myself to everyone else I'm like
so hi my name is Burt it's very nice to
meet you the sad part of that is I don't
remember names very well so I don't
either about you know it's so funny as I
hate bring back tomorrow I always have a
bunch of porn star friends yeah whatever
name you give me the first time i meet
you is your name forever yeah yeah if
you if you go hey I'm Sarah double anal
for the rest of your life it's I don't
care who you are you are Sarah double
anal that's your life that's just how it
is so I meet these girls and you know
through through the show and then
they'll become friends of me and then
they'll be like you know my name is
Michelle Mike I just know you as this
and I you're lucky if you get one name
with me not that I'm anything special
just my brain is chaos and i only have
I'm my storage is full you know you know
I what porn star i really want to meet
jessie andrews do you hear that is now
look her up she is I'm not like I I'd
like I follow her on [ __ ] uh I follow
her on Instagram and her Instagram is
just like she's like the [ __ ] she's
like a Lolita but she's above 20 but
like she's like she's probably 22 pieces
like DJ now she makes jewelry I don't
know if she does porn anymore but all
her friends are like [ __ ] hottie [ __ ]
and they just do like rich girl porn
star stuff like go to Ibiza and DJ and
then hang out on [ __ ] boats and yeah
don't don't wear tops and don't shave
their pubes like just [ __ ] hit I'm like
what the [ __ ] she is so hot instagram
models or so i always tell comedians man
you gotta think like an Instagram model
I know it sounds so weird but Instagram
models own package their whole [ __ ]
there their whole brand they are all
about packaging their brand selling it
the people maximizing the reach of their
brand comedians got to do that yeah you
know through the podcasting the video
blogs and all you just got to sell your
brand to everybody like the you know the
great thing about the Internet is like
it loud allowed the hookers to pimp
themselves they didn't need a pimp so
they have their instagrams they're all
that [ __ ] and they're pimping themselves
out instead of having some dude at the
pimp amount keep all the [ __ ] it's
the most um
amazing thing I've ever washed in my
life yeah and I can't stop liking bimbos
on Instagram and I you know I feel bad
like oh I'm liking all these Phil you
know I'm 40 I don't care I like filth I
like filthy chicks to bend over chairs
and be like have a great monday and you
just see their [ __ ] and i [ __ ]
love it and i'm tired about apologize
ever since i started counting if it's
always been apologizing for who the [ __ ]
I am I make filthy guy I like being
called the N word when I [ __ ] who I am
that's who I am I like being called the
N word I don't know why this Mexican did
it to me and now I'm hooked on it and
it's a weird moment when you ask girl
call you the M word but you know that's
why I'm into and I'm tired of
apologizing I like doing all that [ __ ]
that's who I am I like in Sakai like
liking [ __ ] on Instagram and I mean
that in a kind way that's who i am i'm
tired of it ladies and gentlemen Sam
Tripoli [ __ ] best [ __ ] rent I've
ever heard so I believe please tell me
you're talking about that I'll stay and
I am and you know what else I'm talking
about you know what's so amazing about
is I saw this uh she doesn't do point
more but this girl named ryan keely and
she's like at one point you know and
everybody ages and she's still really
young and really hot but there was a
moment when I have this great show
called the rock and pole world
championships and slowly karaoke and
pole dancing teams compete against each
other it's literally the best live show
you will ever see in your life well I'm
about it I'm gonna do one and I think
early march it's the great show you'll
ever see live holy [ __ ] yeah it's my
greatest invention it makes a naughty
show look like a [ __ ] a dog show it's
like it's literally gracing ryan keely
showed up I've never seen a human being
more hotter in person in my life than
when she showed up last night we were
talking and she's like this Rogan hate
me does he hate and he's like you are so
good and like just talking to you today
we're all in our [ __ ] heads oh so
[ __ ] much and you know dude I'm sober
guy you're not you know I go to I go I
go to 12-step programs man and the most
enlightening freeing thing I ever
learned is that nobody gives a [ __ ]
about me not
negative way nobody's thinking about me
dude yeah everybody's like Burt crushers
in his head hoping he doesn't bomb at
the connoisseur he doesn't get heated
Burt didn't say hi to me last night not
because he doesn't like me cuz Bert
Kreischer is scared off his [ __ ]
skull that he might bomb in a [ __ ]
giant show has nothing to do with me man
yeah that's everybody everybody's so
[ __ ] all exact I think oh my god is he
nobody cares dude everybody wishes you
well on your journey nobody gives a fat
is the [ __ ] truth nobody gives a [ __ ]
no yeah is so [ __ ] freeing dude to
know that you are not alone but nobody
cares listen whatever weird [ __ ] you're
into / I'm sure you're in some weird
[ __ ] everything you don't want to talk
about on the podcast that's [ __ ] cool
but just know everybody's in the weird
[ __ ] yeah everybody's got a weird thing
a dark secret there is a body buried
somewhere in the skull that nobody wants
to [ __ ] talk about and that's why I
get on sales like I like getting called
the N word as I blast chicks in the
[ __ ] that's who I [ __ ] am I don't
give a [ __ ] I [ __ ] love you man you
are [ __ ] I gotta say something you I
love you so much you don't understand
and sometimes i feel really bad cuz i
found you i love you know it so thankful
you put me on this podcast and you're so
nice and I felt like I just bullied this
guy in the blue me no not dude here's
the thing I tell you this and and I
actually thought this because of you
texting your hair wanna be on the
podcast and I was like oh [ __ ] yeah in
my head I would I'm afraid to ask people
to be on my podcast because I feel like
going like ya know we've talked about my
podcast for can we can you just come and
hang out so that i can send stuff to my
fans and i feel bad and the only other
person that's like you that has texted
me and said hey man i'd love to be on
the podcast just so you know is [ __ ]
doug benson and both you guys are i
consider friends but I feel like I'd be
bothering you if I know the only podcast
yeah we going back to sell analyzing
everything it's just like I you know
another thing like I've I'm Armenian an
Italian you know I got [ __ ] fire for
blood dude yeah and I come from
whoa [ __ ] man and you know I could do
everything myself and like I the the
hardest thing I've ever asked learned is
like it's okay to ask people for stuff
ask for a lil more about that I'm
horrible that was great at that who and
I mean this with all love and respect is
Dean Del Rey I want Dean Del Rey to
write a book called how to meet and
greet people cuz he's the best at
[ __ ] doing it I've watched your dad
it's just like no dude you don't know
how many people just are just hey man
help me help me help me hey man help me
help me help me and it gets up does
everything happen no but they put it out
there again don't be afraid to ask for
help that's the biggest thing especially
in sobriety this really great stuff
study just came out and they found what
is addiction what's what's a big thing
in addiction and they found that most
people have strong addictions because
they feel alone and disconnected [ __ ]
dude I all that story I just told you
I'm writing about the reason I'm writing
about it is because in that story is the
most alone and disconnected I've ever
felt in life and it's how I feel the
majority the ways like last night last
night and I don't know if everyone does
this like last night there was a moment
where we're all in the green room at the
store and and I and everyone was talking
to someone and I wasn't talking anyone
and I was like I don't know if everyone
does this but I was like you look
foolish you're not talking anybody like
wait what are you like yeah in my head
up it's just like you said I'm in my
head to anyone else looking they're like
birch ply thinking about his set or
whatever but I'm just going like do I
start a conversation with somebody like
do I jump into a conversation and then
Bobby Bobby Lee walked in Bobby Lee's
like right are we gonna pocket like it
was and then he sat next and then he
goes can I sit next to you and I was
like oh my god you have no idea what a
[ __ ] lie saying yeah what'll I save
you are now I'm talking about believe I
want to talk to and I was like I was
like whoa but yeah I'm [ __ ] I'm in
mind I have crippling social anxiety i
get my mother Vic I've gone to birthday
parties walked in wish people happy
birthday walk to rate the [ __ ] out of
the party cuz the reason I left last
night as I go I go listen I can hang out
I could drink all night I
can have a good time by good at some
point when do I say goodbye like do I am
i jut like what if I don't know a lot of
people what if I'm just hanging out next
to red band all night and he's gonna be
like Burt you should go get walk around
I'm like well I don't know if I I'm
afraid of like it I deed that's so funny
we just over analyze every and then I
saw the video on Kate's periscope but I
was like damn it I saw you and I go I
know trip lose Erica [ __ ] hung out
all night yeah right win8 dude two
pornstars Nate Diaz k quickly what a
great life we live oh I thought but then
i but then i got home i smoke cigar I
got to bed at a really good time last
night for me I probably like midnight
but uh but I can I finish this vlog I
posted the vlog and I was like okay all
right let's just work hard and play hard
later I guess I don't [ __ ] know I'm
seeing the face Joey's so interesting he
others jessiemae peluso um Joe so
interesting he doesn't like texting but
then he'll text you and but he doesn't
want you to reply to him yeah he's like
don't it's like dog I don't phunk
attacks then he text me the funniest
thing was when Tom Segura did a either
he did her son else did a group text I
think you were in it I was in nrt was in
it red band was in it and a couple other
people are in it and we're all texting
each other and Joey Diaz was in it and
it Joey Diaz started threatening Tom
cigars life his phone just kept blowing
up with respective Elmo [ __ ] kill you
dog and Tom's good please stop texting
on this thing joy Diaz getting so pissed
dude sir I want you a lying for a moment
with [ __ ] Tom cigars kid Tom and
Christina's kid as the like the [ __ ]
the comedy prince has arrived how funny
is that kid gonna be he's he's you know
he's gonna be he's gonna be the kind of
funny that tom is where it's like toms
not over the top beating you over
seventh sense of humor hanging out with
him he makes you laugh non-stop and it's
that subtle stuff for it's just that the
kid's gonna be he's gonna be thought a
walking around inside joke like he'll
say this [ __ ] under his breath that will
[ __ ] destroy you miss Thomas
incredibly smart and like people are
people do realize that but he is
insanely smart I mean like he knows
Spanish he knows all the [ __ ] he's like
he works at a higher level uh I actually
got Tom score in the comedy you know in
the stand-up comedy you know that no we
we were doing a Groundlings class
together and you know a gun recognizes a
gun yeah kids scared me so I was like I
gotta be friends with this guy cuz he
was so fast and I was like dude you're
so fast you're so funny cuz somebody did
this to me in Vegas you should do
stand-up comedy's like really I'm like
yeah man i'll take you around so for the
week I took him to every comedy show
that I knew and he started doing
stand-up and and he's just like he's
someone I did he could write a book
about and it's it's interesting and
maybe it's just part of his persona or
MIT party supporters person's
personality like he's someone who like
just could get in with great comics and
they'd take him with him to like amazing
places but he's not the guy that calls
people up like Rogan can you get me on
hey Santa Russell Peters can you take me
the o2 arena and open for you he doesn't
do that but they but everyone loves him
including myself I mean I took him to
one of his first road gigs uh up in
Sacramento I [ __ ] he bombed so bad
you have I'll never forget I remember
the I said to the club i'm bringing my
own feature he's [ __ ] hilarious he
bombed for 25 minutes every single night
and i remember one point the manager
going I thought you said he was funny I
go he is you just you don't get it they
don't get it but I get it like I totally
understand that like it's getting lost
on this road club because everyone's
[ __ ] mouth breathing and licking
windows but [ __ ] and and the only
reason I'm doing good except bad habits
and I'm like [ __ ] who loves to eat
[ __ ] and they're like this is my
20-minute chunk that it everyone has
kind of done a version of right now
we're gonna do a verse
right babe Tom's not doing that and then
we drove home and he was like he's like
that you dig the heavy pack he's he is
one of my favorite he's one of my
favorite human beings I told him I we
went out to dinner me him and push this
I did this an episode of my vlog on this
so if you wanna go to my vlog on a / / /
by now you know that if you're listening
this but and I said to him I go dude do
a vlog I go start a vlog and just I go
just run the camera edit it together but
henan push are so funny together they
ordered this because they're not leaving
the outside the baby they got this
takeout delivery system they
accidentally ordered like five pounds of
bacon oh he's like and but it's Tom
doing it so you can see it it's like so
I remember begging with everything weed
but I [ __ ] love that guy I did
christina pazsitzky is a assassin she is
funny as [ __ ] she's an assassin she's
got the thing that all funny women when
I say funny women I just mean in life
that before you saw stand up women in on
stage when you met a woman who is funny
you you recognized it in a weird way you
got a crush on them immediately and like
funny women and I just like funny guys
that almost like the definition of a
funny guy to everyone was like I think
Adam Carolla said it was a guy who could
do an Ace Ventura impression there's
that type of guy who thinks he's funny
he's like alrighty then and he just does
like his Borat impression all the time
and you're like enough that's not funny
but a funny guy a real funny guy girls
had a crush on real funny women men get
crushes on and they always had like an
ability to make an inside joke that only
you and them appreciated and you almost
were like god this one's enriching my
life yeah i love i love smart women I
like fast women I love female comics man
there's all this you know it's a fine I
was doing the hooters club last night
and it like after the club it's an open
mic and so the rooms full of open my
curse and I this one very attractive
female comics it sound I just started
talking to her and I'm like so how do
you think it is being a female comic
she's really cool about it you know but
I listen to a lot of female comics
how hard is the female comic I'm like
the truth is it's hard on everybody it
literally is hard on everybody you have
a you know some people here and you want
think that represents the whole group
and it's really not like that it's hard
on everybody the thing I will tell you
about female comics is like they have a
parachute there used to be these two
crazy twin comics who would hang by the
comedy store all the time they were
doing comedy but they really just
[ __ ] with a comedy store bikes you
know what I'm saying like everybody's
riding them and up one day they just
disappear I don't see him for like two
years I'm walking to the improv she
pulls up in a brand new land rover I'm
like what's going on she's like I got
married I'm dating it boom that's her
parachute out you know all my male
friends who do comedy in the 40s are
doing now medical testing they're all
[ __ ] doing medical testing they're
all [ __ ] lab rats taking pills hoping
that they don't get a dick growing out
of their [ __ ] forehead grifoni 10
grand that's what they're all [ __ ]
doing dude like that's the that's the
401k for a [ __ ] comic let me take
some bills don't let it take her out of
my forehead I'm gonna lay on this table
for one month straight without using my
muscle yeah to simulate what spaces like
astronauts that's so funny they would go
to Pesci you know my friends are doing
medical that's what they're all doing
dude it's so funny because like you do
like I'm not like and I'm sure that
Eliza would argue this point but I'm not
saying that that I'm not definitely not
saying she will not be doing stand-up
for the rest of life but however if she
chooses to stop because of some
emotional crux that we all have at some
point we were like what the [ __ ] are we
talking about what the [ __ ] are we doing
I don't feel like I'm saying anything
original she definitely could marry any
[ __ ] oh she's so hot she's so
beautiful he's on bow yeah she Whitney
Cummings Christina 20 companies could
literally I'm not saying that I think
Whitney's players I think should be
doing center for the rest of life I do I
can see both of them both of them i'm
not saying they've already seen ever the
yeah but they're [ __ ] hilarious
chicks do you know how many [ __ ]
good-looking pro athlete millionaires
would love
to spend time with the [ __ ] funny i
love you i was talking about that last
night's like you know what you know i
was talking about the medical tests
things like women could always jump on
Rick rich dicks yeah you know guys can't
jump on rich snatch women there's no
such thing as trickle-down [ __ ] you
know they don't [ __ ] broke dick for fun
they women always got [ __ ] up that's why
I feel bad for famous women to be honest
with you because they always want to
[ __ ] alpha males and the problem with
alpha males is that all the females are
going for elf you know it's a weird
thing it's like Whitney Cummings just
you know Julia Roberts is such a unique
person cuz she literally [ __ ] like the
best grip on this on sat like you know
how rare that is the [ __ ] the best grip
nobody [ __ ] bastard bushes named
Danny I knew his name specifically cuz
there's a hero she was at a party I went
to one time uh we went to a party at
like Christmas party Danny he was good
friends with our friend they were both
grips yeah and he was a really [ __ ]
solid guy ended up talking to him all
night not knowing it was Julia Roberts
husband and Julie Roberts was on the
couch she was on the couch she was
looking at belts I want to say Jan yeah
I wish Danny motor yeah William motor
out there everybody Julia motor but it's
like Whitney it's like she can't just
[ __ ] anybody what do you mean she wants
to [ __ ] these women want to [ __ ] up oh
yeah yeah yeah by the way did I her
winning on Rogan's podcaster nose and it
sounds like it sounds like a [ __ ]
nightmare to be her and single like it
sounds like there's like dudes have ish
dudes have issues with her money dudes
have or she has issues with dudes having
issues with her money it sounds like
from what I was experiencing on a
podcast that it's like it's gonna be a
[ __ ] to be hot rich and funny
yeah and talented and driven that's the
other thing all those women are driven
always say to myself what would Whitney
do that's what I say to myself some
mornings where I thought of her
yesterday as i was going to the store i
thought i thought i wish i had there was
something about her when i first met her
that I was like I saw her to stand up
and I was like she's really strong on
stage she when she was right
I you know dude I feel like sometimes we
all know dude that girl is a legit
assassin but she's really she's really
she's really driven like she's and I
wish I had her drive i wish like I was a
screen on stage anyone else I just go
you know you see what happened with her
she's one of the cool that you saw and
you were like oh this is gonna happen
like if I was smart I would hang out
hang around her a lot Jeffrey Ross says
she did 10 years of work in five years
she just worked smart the biggest thing
Whitney has in like this is a blessing
and a curse i feel is like she knows she
knows how to talk to the suits she knows
the words they want to hear and the way
they want to hear it and she's an
amazing human being at being able to
dictate her thoughts in a way that they
love here to the point that it's so
effective that sometimes it can be
detrimental and the reason I say that is
like that show she did Whitney was funny
I don't give a [ __ ] what anybody said
but she was so able to convince them
that was so good that they put so much
money in advertising that it became it
was impossible for it to do [ __ ] what
it was expected to do it was just in my
she was getting like Jim Carrey returns
a television kind of promotion you know
yeah yeah yeah yeah where's Italy she
would have came in on the kind on the
radar it could have built up and could
do I wanted to say I wanted to say that
the real [ __ ] winner out of that show
was D'Elia oh one other reason he was so
good on that show he was good actor 02
he's an amazing he is a genuine to I saw
I saw him last night he was very nice
but man I he when I saw my Whitney I was
like dude this guy comes into a scene
steals the scene with no energy he's not
trying to steal a scene he just as
charismatic he's funny he's like my
cables [ __ ] I talked I've said this on
other podcast I'm sure I'll say it a
million other times one of the things I
love about him he wants to be a action
story said that on Ron Bennington's
podcast or uh unmasked dude I believe
that could [ __ ] happen I believe he's
a not yeah why not I believe that I'd
[ __ ] go if he gets an action movies
I will go see that [ __ ] movie opening
week yeah and I I make a ton of people
would he's so [ __ ] likable dude he's
like you know I've had to follow that
guy in a [ __ ] comedy thank God I
didn't have to follow him last night I
was like he's a weird guy do well after
I don't know why him you know who I
found it to other people I found like
how did that go well and he just went
well daniel tosh 0 and then David tell
oh those are two guys that I can't like
I like them so much that I'm nd i
watched their whole set as a fan and
then I go oh [ __ ] I gotta do the same
magic tricks they just did I don't have
that in me right now yes there's i want
i want i'm the guy following this oh
dude tosh is tosh is someone that I
believe is probably i think a lot of
people that are my people my age go of
the guy on comedy central like I think a
lot of college kids watching they love
him I think he is someone who could do a
tour he could do there's a market that
is not buying tickets to a show that
would [ __ ] humble of that guy one
hundred percent you know who's just
sneaky superstar like I think people do
realize but he never gets talked about
in the conversation of just the greatest
comics TJ Miller nobody talks about that
guy like everyone's like oh I want this
guy ba ba ba I was like no teaching me
Jay Miller is an out-of-the-box [ __ ]
think or two by the way these are these
are all people successful like we've
just talked about krista lea waiting
nobody touch him what that guy is doing
right now oh yeah no but I mean a
successful show a legitimate successful
show it is a silicon valley is one of
the funniest shows on television no
questions asked he is a [ __ ] hardcore
scene stealer in it when he gives the
closing speech when he there's a moment
where he's got to give a speech at a
tech conference and uh and he's [ __ ]
someone's wife or something dude TJ
Miller and and another thing about TJ
and I this is and by the way these are
all people I would never reach out to do
a podcast with I would never so I never
reach out to TJ had never reach out to
me to did but here's your podcast no but
like I just I just knew want like I like
them all but I would feel very
uncomfortable
like I have a problem texting patent do
it but I put with TJ I go I don't wanna
I don't want to force him to do it I
don't want him to resent I don't want
him to go in Deadpool dude he's on the
trailer for Deadpool how great is that
trailer I was [ __ ] awesome I
literally SAT there watching the trailer
and TJ's in there and I was like
[ __ ] now it is the yeah he's a
[ __ ] you know else's great Ryan
Reynolds doesn't get enough like to Ryan
Reynolds is worth every 20 million
dollars they give him that guy [ __ ]
his timing is insane i would i would
give a should not be that bad kind of
comedic timing yeah it's unbelievable to
the point that i almost think it hurts
him because we were like he's too
good-looking yeah dude he's so good i
always saw parallel between ryan
reynolds and Dane Cook yeah I always saw
parallel and I was like I was like I
wonder if either of them know who the
other one is they did that movie
together oh [ __ ] yeah they did waiting
yeah I was a great [ __ ] movie that
wasn't big gain went for like the Dane
had the out [ __ ] out their character
with the tattoos on his face or whatever
I I yeah Ryan Reynolds is legit man I
could there's a lot of comics I [ __ ]
love you know that's all one of the
things about the stories you are end up
really [ __ ] loving comedy like
there's some clubs you go to where
you're like God [ __ ] this guy [ __ ] this
club I [ __ ] hate it man you come out
of the store for one night I did two
nights back to back and I'm like goddamn
it man there's a like there's a ton of
great comics Steve Agee Steve Agee
[ __ ] destroyed last night yeah he
destroyed so [ __ ] hard he was like
well adjust I'm not gonna do one of his
jokes but but cuz that would be [ __ ]
not cool because I'd [ __ ] it up and then
be like he's not that funny but Manny he
had a joke about hemorrhoids that I was
off to the wings and I was laughing so
hard I couldn't stop laughing I couldn't
stop laughing at him [ __ ] just
meandering through a bit like just kind
of [ __ ] you know Steve it like he is
[ __ ] amazing dude it is amazing time
and comedy it is like you think about it
Sandler's back David
spades back uh all these guys that I
dude I would I'd pay money to see
David's wipers money to see adam sandler
and now they're going on tour with
Swardson all these guys are back all its
gonna do is breathe excitement about
comedy and I'm telling you man it is the
best fear to be on the road it is a
great time dude it is a great time to do
comedy because like there's not a lot of
rules out you could as long as it's
funny you could almost talk about
anything now thanks to you know tosh
point-o and workaholics and and uh South
Park to work all such a great [ __ ]
shoot it is so the end of this podcast
is gonna be titled Burton Sam sucking
everyone's yeah yeah hey guys just do us
a little [ __ ] just show us some love
on when you talk and go man Burton samer
[ __ ] hilarious dude I'm blow banging
everybody right now I'm sucking 18 dicks
on this [ __ ] podcast right now yeah
dude I think it's a great time to comedy
I love it when I go on the road it's a
totally different experience man I used
to be like I hope these guys like me
when I walked up Bobby but you think
that I hope they get it you know now
it's like [ __ ] dude as long as it's
funny dude as long as it's funny feel
give it a shot it's like even mitten in
the Midwest sometimes midwestern crowds
and floor like Florida's great for
commie they're better than [ __ ] West
Coast crowds but Arizona is great
everywhere is great I'm like San
Francisco's great Canada's phenomenal
it's just like what a fun place to do
calm yes just a great time and you don't
man I am I owe my whole career to the
internet just because I'm putting out
content i'm finding people i'm finding
people i'm finding people and they know
my comedy like it's so weird to be in a
foreign city people like Tripoli what's
when do you think it's going to be the
time that someone steps up and says Sam
I'd like to own all your content how
much can I pay you so that when you make
something I own it and would you like a
long time ago try to but was it um it
wasn't [ __ ] you money so I'm like now
dude like everything I would be the
price point will be the price point
except for someone to step up right now
and go I would like to I like to be in
the business of Sam Tripoli I would like
to own fifty percent of all the content
you put on out from here on out I'll do
that's a great question what is
your number do you have a number I'm
never I'd have to think about that again
i can come up with a number pretty
quickly um I can honestly no I be she be
shocked I'd do it for to own all my
everything I put a half of everything
you put out half of half of everything I
probably do it for seven hundred
thousand dollars that's not bad number
70 by the way a year did they just own
it for a year for one nope no I get pic
[ __ ] i don't know I maybe I'm [ __ ]
this up for I did if you said to me if
you should I probably for less another
I'm thinking about it if you said four
I'll give you I'll give you half a
million dollars a year let's I'll give
you half a million dollars here and I
will own half of all the content you put
out there if it sells in perpetuity I
will still own half if it goes viral I
own half I get half your ad sales in
your podcast I got half your ad sales on
your YouTube channels I can I probably
do it for probably half a million
dollars now if you want to talk about
putting that into folding that into
travel like like travel channel working
for travel channel it would be much more
to do a TV show because TV shows so
you're so intense but i'm talking like
just what I'm puttin out right now cuz
is they should I I do I do for free yeah
I love it for five hundred thousand
dollars i probably consider having a
partner in this where i go a year uh uh
yeah I go a hundred thousand dollars a
year just you can give half my [ __ ] yeah
and you go to a hundred thousand dollars
a year you want to worry about you give
me a partner let's say let's say mark
cuban rolled up listen someone do me a
favor if you're listening and you know
Mark Cuban send is this his way I think
this is a good I think this is an
interesting business plan a hundred
thousand dollars I probably do this I
probably I by self 250 I'd sell no
questions asked down to fifty dollars a
year you don't even suggest content and
Mark Cuban says listen this is what I
want I want half
blood shark tank and Kim and pitch that
I want half of everything you do I don't
want you to slow down production because
you getting paid 2050 thousand dollars
now you're on vacation I want you to
produce a few late what you have to put
out yeah and and and I want you to keep
creating and I want for that half I want
to be able to do with it what I want so
mark cuban you go i sold it to the
Sultan of Brunei he paid like a million
dollars and he any and you can't put it
online but he listen to your podcast by
himself no one else can listen to it
except for the Sultan of Brunei but
here's a million dollars we're gonna
split it I'd [ __ ] I would yeah that's
it interesting that would be an
interesting business plan is to purchase
okay let's let's fold it into this okay
we're doing Shark Tank we're doing Shark
Tank you're selling me I would like to
how about this what would it cost [ __ ] I
don't know if there's maybe i'm not good
at business but like what would it cost
for him to to get are you allowed to
renegotiate that's my question like what
is it are you like an NBA player are you
saying a five-year
hundred-thousand-dollar year contract
it's what if you blow up you ready for
this a ten year contract so you're
guaranteeing the money you've put in
yourself already we're all guaranteeing
than in 10 years or something very
massives happening with our careers yes
we're definitely oh I plan on getting
bigger than I am today ten-year contract
same price point every year for ten
years would you sign a million-dollar
contract where you get a hundred
thousand dollars for the next ten years
yes I would in a heartbeat and I'm take
twice about it with the freedom of that
I would just go effing crazy dude on
everything I would go effing I would be
put out the craziest weirdest [ __ ] ikea
I think I mean if I would do it for 2.5
million dollars if you gave me 250
thousand dollars a year because i think
it 250 thousand dollars a year i could
lead
I'm talking I'm talking now well because
you break that down its gonna be like
100 after taxes such a TV show he gets
half of what you make of it if I'm when
I go get to travel channel he gets half
of my page I think you're gonna get hit
up by somebody if Ida Jallow might be
like I'll invited Oh hit up her you're
basically offering stock options in my
career you should do that i'll give you
forty nine percent of my career I still
want to be the controlling owner of what
I do you want 51% oppression enterprise
Mark Cuban i'm offering 49 i'm offering
forty-nine percent of my career to you
dude you should see view them pitch ends
i mean even if it doesn't get picked up
and just come out and just go hey guys
my name is Bert Kreischer I'm a stand-up
comedian of a podcast from a vlogger I'm
a television host I'm an actor and in
1997 Rolling Stone magazine Carmen the
number one party and I'm on the country
I'm 43 years old I have two children I'm
also a safe bet I don't drop the n-word
I I don't [ __ ] say too outrageous of
[ __ ] but I'm talented yeah we'd like to
offer you forty-nine percent ownership
in my company for 2.5 million dollars
over the next 10 years I dude you should
right now call up shark tank it seems to
let you do that and then Mark Cuban go
oh you know what cuz Mark Cuban could
then go I'll take it and i'll make you a
[ __ ] star and i'll just get a root
investment on my money mark cuban just
takes me to every single game it with
him hey guys it's bert right yeah we're
take your shirt off for the night record
set one hundred percent that would be
[ __ ] great it would be great dude
that's that's my [ __ ] that's my shark
tank you should have your agents call up
shark tank see if you can pitch right
now my agents will be like 2.5 over ten
years is not a lot of money by the way
did I move my math right I think I did
my math right Julie thousand those year
they would be happy with that and I'm
getting I'm also getting fifty one
percent of the money that I bring it i
mean you can't work it just means all
right you're getting half of what you're
talking about yeah so you can even
stipulate that i'm getting two hundred
thousand dollars a year and i'm getting
on top like if I do nothing that you're
in half of what you make me you pay out
you tell your agents I'm paying you out
this and then he gets half of what I
make does it affect their bottom line
and I got more human in my pocket
there's like who's okay you got art
first of all
I think we're gonna have access I think
we can move the company to Dallas yeah
I'm like well I am 51-percent owner but
you guys have a pool of my kids can go
swimming in all right we're going to
dallas you you be on access TV which is
only gonna get bigger you'll be on you
could do some stuff on MSNBC I got ten
year I got a 10-year parachute where I
know I'm not going anywhere for ten
years I can really make the content I
want yeah I start making my content it
goes on axis and you're still making
road money you're still making dildoing
the road you're making a little less now
that you're giving half of that up oh
yeah and but that's fine I'm sure ok
let's do well your money will go walk
because you're the guy from shark tank
who sold half his brand you will make up
in what you give up and then in like
little things like I'm wearing Mavericks
[ __ ] everywhere I go I think you should
do it dude I think you're in a great
place to do that that's a gram wonder if
I can do that all right we gotta we
should probably end this podcast Jody it
should be I love you in all my heart and
if Joey comes over and you're still here
I'd kind of like both you here but I
don't know I gotta see em all right I
would tell them about the tome about the
thing it's the man he tore slow
punchlines and slow grinds through the
Northeast January nineteenth through the
30th go to Sam Tripoli calm for all the
info and then next week is the naughty
show at The Comedy Store host spots my
fleshlight none of the people of fleshly
dude they're great we're gonna do some
more projects too and you got you got a
plunger Bobby Lee Tiffany Haddish you
gotta have her on your podcast i turned
to that for a long time ah Jason tebow
Jason rouse and L go Eleanor Kerrigan
and just check out me and Chad sumac if
you're in northeast we're coming to a
city near you I guarantee you you will
have the best time ever it will be
murder fest Sam I Love You Man thank and
go to CD com I just put out my old CD
for the first time digitally the first
CD I ever met with some flocking classic
sonic rules so go to CD com backslash
artist backslash
love you were human thank you
you
this episode was brought to you by the
Machine
you